yoth spécial chanteuse se retrouve sur
after vesdun avec lugos unis car bonjour
toi terme et les mecs font n'importe
quoi ils me font des doigts ils ont mal
au monde pas juste les raids aériens de
bach aux achats cela pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est un survival en
ligne et en gros c'est un monde infesté
de zombies et le but c'est de vivre
voilà où ça le cas tu fais plus jamais
ça actuellement de but ça va être de en
fait on va demander d'aider à
ravitaillement par avion le truc c'est
que toute la manne va voir l'avion il va
revenir là où il lâche le colis et vu
que là on n'a pas dernier rien eh ben on
va nous voler notre colis déjà et nous
défoncer en suisse j'entends quelqu'un
ya quelqu'un allait il faudra que les
ont ils fait honneur à la vidéo fait le
buzz comme comme rien au hockey
mcafee vaseux défense tient je m'allonge
sur toi bercy dans cette vidéo
voilà c'est bon on est prêt cole fois un
drop les gars là stress et comment tu
sais pas où ils arrivent battu l'entente
ne voit pas mais cas si je vois que des
louanges et au jockey lâche le colis oui
la liesse auquel il ya le colis est
bientôt là je répète le coulis bientôt
la pause et a pété mais avoir des
zombies boom des envies du pipi c'est
parti à tan tan tan pardo il ya deux
mecs à gauche les gars données sur le
colis donc pas le cas il en a donné en
deuxième je défonce s'est chopé g7
choper make me secondes tu d'envieux on
comprend tout dans ce bar j'ai dirigé
tout prix quel mec j'ai tout pris non je
suis assez
mais je sais pas mais c'est ce clavier
américain de montcuq actuellement un
abonné a reconnu mika dans le jeu et du
coup mickaël recrute ça bah oui aux plus
dures
on recrute une vraie armée pour bien
péter la gueule de ce qui vient de voler
notre colis bordel aux mondiaux s'est
retrouvée bon bah c'est bien on a
recruté quelqu'un on peut être très
content au [ __ ] t'es machette
ohlala mais là on verra répond dans leur
cité on va leur péter la gueule
l'avion vient d'avion il y en avait eu
les gars ont tracé ovale son colis ces
partis go go go
voilà comment est ce qu'on attend devant
l'avion finalement avant partir au
combat les devants aux locaux au [ __ ]
ils apposaient connus ou pas déjà il
vient de chez les gardes a lâché on pas
qu'on allait le mener jusqu'à a été
repéré à la gare chaque année des halles
l'équipe d'intervention est en cours
pour le logement le volet j'ai planté
les gars repos 3 merde mais faisait tout
le monde a planté non voilà le bon gros
bug fait plaisir en plein rush pour
sauver pour en plus à faire notre devoir
déjà désamorcé un colis suspect à
châtelet-les-halles mais on fait quand
même qu'on attaque et c'est ça ouais y'a
un mec sur un ring la colline a des yeux
du cac on tient la coulée la tête des
yeux rumeurs et potins pékin mickaël
tape mais quatre défenses toutes et tous
que ce collier de nouilles parce que tu
lui abîme et moi en tant que spectateur
c'est très puissant
on va voir ce qui se passe les gars
équipes d'intervention squat b2 fallait
y aller même pas alors ils ont plus
colis non expression l'affairé
laisserait plus bien non ce qu'ils
attaquent tout le monde apparemment
ouais on regarde regarde c'est vrai
charlas moyens s'ils voient pas le gros
truc est en train de but et nous sommes
battus contre hugues la loose la pointe
de caux les [ __ ] attentant venez on
laisse l'ours tué tout le monde et
ensuite on tue l'ourson prendre colis
aux mecs thema c'est incroyable ce qui
attend venait viser les joueurs
répondent ses joies et un tombe toujours
le fric ou hi hi hi hi
j'ai mis une flèche dans l'ours ah ouais
j'ai perdu soins j'ai perdu 100 l'égail
à l'ours courez courez courez criaient
politique celle en train de charger
c'est bondé saute au dessus de la
barrière pas sauter il me course encore
ballet quotidien on peut les récupérer
tous les débris mais dégage fait quoi
aller sans qu ils parlent quand josé
cendon à la faute
ses moyens enfin [ __ ] oh [ __ ] j'ai
que 13% de vie attend les s'il vous
plaît voilà alors il ya eu cure post
goggles des binocular un compas un ca de
shell bon bah c'est pas mal déjà ce
qu'ils avaient fait fort les gars bien
c'est un mec en face c'est pas bien mais
qu il va nous tirer dessus les gars y'a
l'avion qui arrivait pas fait gaffe la
veille un mec avec un arc
je vais le défoncer mais juste un mec
non à tuer et dans la caravane je vais
tenter une flèche salut moi je me la
mets dans la tête je rage quit un lien
entre ou quoi peut-on regarder un drop
il ya trois mecs là bas et avec un mec
là y'a un mec internes n'ont été avertis
et la moitié ma vie je veux où je veux
plus mourir très fier d'eux
oui j'ai car 70 reprendre la limite je
me suis d'abord terme l'apport des
chiottes changera de montvert fermture
attendait les témoins très déçu moi
entrer des noms d'amis aussi la fugière
turballais mec je n'ai plus de vie et je
vous en supplie les gars j'aimerais man
divo quelques pansements qu'un mec à
côté non obtient mais j'entends s'est
pas préparé l'arc à tant de gens ont
alors fait appel à comme fear my little
pony
je trouvais ça se trouve ils sont
exactement d'imposition que nous mais
dans le coin côté de la porte
les gars jouent la part vous êtes prêts
vous êtes prêt à jeter
ils sont là bas j'ai vu un mec dr david
j'ai pu m'aider à lavit j'ai refermé
jarre faire bloc et préparez-vous lalala
les notes de l'autre côté du mur fait
gaffe ici que ce serait la faute au
temps où hugo attention les cadres aussi
à mourir
j'étais en plein dans sa tête mais gégé
ils sont là ils savent où ils savent je
sais je sais je sais le droit à du souci
la porte dès qu'ils nous t'aimons lui
retient dans des sachets en mika n'a
vraiment d'une voiture on est de part et
d'autre de la porte mais qu en mai
jusqu'à une flèche vers le mur hier dans
le cou this is our love them
we want to paint ou boucle ce qu'il a
dit mais qu'est ce que vous pouvez
prendre les 24
hugo n'ai pas encore vu jusqu'à nous on
est heureux on est de retour à la
station service parce que c'est nos
[ __ ] de toile est alors on va leur
montrer bordeaux allait changer mais
encore assez bac c'est le même cas et
voici ego un toner de cailloux de
fougères coin là on va les tuer du
zombie à côté de l'église d'accord
rarement ils sont censés l'outil un
certain nombre de chances pour qu'il
août est une clé avec un coffre
ok donc droit au but un seul but aura
une chance qu'on est une clé dessus pour
ouvrir un coffre aux trésors
nous sommes à l'église honte on est
tombé sur ça que mec qu'a pas dans
l'église mais c'est la guerre les gars
c'est chaud dans taille avec qui rigole
non mais t'es pas s'être encore attirer
après huit années de galère nous sommes
sous la tour sous laquelle il ya ce
fameux coffre à que higuain rouvrir avec
la clé qui a trompé sur un zombie on y
va en premier album étoiles bien
derrière nous yasser [ __ ] ya un verbe
et fait partie du contenu inattendu au
lait n'est là qu'un mec mais toi tu es
un meeting au violon et chant allez les
gars je viens d'appeler un air drop
celui-là on shoppe dtp qui tourne vers
lui alors il le lâche ou quoi allez bon
voilà c'est parti c'est parti c'est
parti auquel cas on se cache ici et où
lucas je suis dans lé bella je suis là
je sais mais b non mais on occulte
ok ok c'est parti c'est bon les gars
chute dont il ya un piège de l'eau des
choses nulles 3,9 en quoi c'est la fin
de la vidéo vous est pourquoi pas ce
modèle car pack lutins ça fait six
heures autour mais ça vous le savez pas
de sympathie
j'aurais dû effectuer et quand je le
pouvais mouallem à l'agencé tap cette
vidéo sur un chien z à un prix jouer
avec ses potes ni je veux pas avec vous
savez pas ce que c'est tout simplement
galère aura passé quatre heures à ceux
recherchés
à chaque fois qu'on moore et c'est un
[ __ ] d'en faire mais ça vous regarde
et n'hésitez pas aimé ça vous a pu
ressentir dans une vidéo sur tout le
monde puisse et je les fais rapidement
vous avez vu